Venom first sank his teeth into fans' brains
decades ago in the pages of The Amazing Spider-Man
comics, giving the antihero a long time to
build up a cast of kooky side characters.
Not surprisingly, a handful of those familiar
names made their way into 2018's Venom, the
symbiote's first solo big screen outing.
Here are some of the characters in Venom who
have way more meaning than you realized.
Major spoilers ahead.
Anne Weying
In Venom, Michelle Williams plays Anne Weying,
Eddie Brock's fiancee - who dumps him after
he snuck information about The Life Foundation
out of her personal files and then accosted
the foundation's CEO, Carlton Drake, in an
interview.
The move gets both of them fired, and Weying
breaks off their engagement.
She later gets catapulted back into his life
when Venom takes over her body so that she
can carry him back to Eddie.
For a few minutes, audiences were treated
to a giant, head-eating female Venom.
That bizarre version of Venom comes straight
out of the comic book miniseries Sinner Takes
All.
In that arc, Venom bonds with Anne to save
her life after Anne gets shot.
Later in the series, they pull the same trick
to get out of a hostage situation, saving
the day by way of perfectly planned bodyswapping.
Carlton Drake
2018's Venom saw Rhiz Amed channeling the
prototypical bad guy in his character, Carlton
Drake.
He's an amoral scumbag who eventually gets
a symbiote of his very own.
He and Venom punch each other a lot, and then
one of them explodes.
In the comics, however, there's a bit more
to this guy's story.
Like many of Venom's adversaries, Carlton
Drake was originally a Spider-Man villain.
He and his nefarious Life Foundation first
showed up in The Amazing Spider-Man #298,
and it only took him a few issues to throw
an army of mutated monsters at Spidey.
His big clash with Venom came in Venom: Lethal
Protector, which also served as one of the
storylines Sony's Venom film was based on.
In that series, Drake concocts a plan to steal
five pieces of Venom and nurture them into
his own symbiote super soldiers.
He succeeds, creating Scream, Phage, Lasher,
Agony, and Riot.
Eventually, Spider-Man and Venom put a stop
to this particular plan, sending Drake back
into hiding to concoct bigger, more devious
schemes which culminate in Drake turning himself
into a giant spider in the Arachnis Project
story arc.
Roland Treece
He didn't have a lot going on in the movie,
but Scott Haze delivered a pretty good henchman
as Roland Treece.
Sure, he got his head eaten in the end, but
it's the journey that counts.
Unfortunately, in this case, that journey
should have been a whole lot bigger.
In his comics incarnation, Treece isn't a
low-level thug who goes out to crummy apartments
to retrieve his boss's lost aliens - he's
an ultra-rich businessman who sits on the
board of directors for The Life Foundation.
Granted, he's still less of a threat to Venom
than Drake, but it's Treece's master plan
to demolish part of the city that sends Spidey
and Venom running back to San Francisco for
the final showdown in Lethal Protector.
And that's all fine.
The Venom movie didn't need multiple masterminds
for its crazy schemes, and there were already
enough bad guys to go around.
At least the movie didn't try to shoehorn
in Venomsaurus Rex.
Wait, who are we kidding?
Venomsaurus Rex would have been the best addition
to this movie.
Scream
In the first act of the movie, we're introduced
to some tanks of goo in the Life Foundation
labs.
Those are the symbiotes that Drake is trying
to merge with human hosts - a project that
goes disastrously wrong.
If you paid close attention, you may have
noticed that one of the symbiotes was distinctly
yellow, which matches another distinctly yellow
symbiote in the comics: Scream.
In Venom: Lethal Protector, Donna Diego was
the human host for Scream, one of the five
symbiotes created by Drake.
She eventually obtained a measure of self
awareness, and gained enough control over
her symbiote to start hunting the other ones.
Fans on the internet speculated that the EMT
who bonds with a symbiote was, in fact, Donna
Diego.
Although we now know that that lady was just
a brief host for the Riot symbiote, her inclusion
- and the fact that she got more screentime
than the other hosts - could be another nod
to Donna Diego.
Maybe.
Cletus Kasady
Before the reviews were even in, Venom was
already setting up a sequel in its Spiderless
Spiderverse.
In the mid-credits scene, we see Woody Harrelson
make an appearance as a red-haired psychopath
in a prison cell who goes by the name Cletus
Kasady.
Comics fans should instantly recognize the
name as the inmate who played host to Venom's
son, Carnage.
"Kasady is gone.
There is only Carnage!"
He may be Venom's son, but Carnage is stronger
and and a whole lot crazier than dear old
dad.
If a Venom sequel gets off the ground, a Woody
Harrelson-played Carnage could be just the
ticket to take things to the next level.